peu d'indicés laissaient présager la
catastrophe jusqu'à ce que des pierres
se met à tomber alertant des témoins en
panique à bord d'autres embarcations
c'était trop peu trop tard samedi en
mi-journée un pente palais s'est détaché
d'un canyon accrochant du même coup des
bateaux avec à leur bord de nombreux
touristes des vidéos de la scène ont
rapidement fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux
sauf
les conditions météorologiques on
ralentit l'opération de sauvetage
beaucoup de pluie des nuages ont empêché
un avion de se rendre sur place les
canyon du lac farnace sont situées à
environ 600 km de rio de janeiro et à
plus de 400 km de sao paulo
selon les pompiers les pluies intenses
des derniers jours dans le sud est du
pays ont pu favoriser la catastrophe une
brigade de plongeurs et un hélicoptère
ont été déployés sur les lieux dodge
charger faire face aux inondations
parmi les victimes des enfants secourus
par les premiers répondants le président
brésilien jaïr bolson araud a tenu à
souligner sur twitter l'intervention
rapide de la marine brésilienne venue au
secours des victimes
le site prisé pour ses eaux vertes ces
parois rocheuses et ses cascades attire
environ 5000 visiteurs chaque week end
ici elisa la radio canada montréal